the cases are surging all across the  country today but now there's a new  focus on young people and why so many of  them are getting the virus cases are up  in nearly 40 states searches among young  people are linked to everything from  fitness classes to summer frat parties  it's not going to really stop me from  like going out I just personally don't  care I haven't got sick yet so experts  are worried because many young people  are asymptomatic and they could  indirectly affect people at a greater  risk new numbers from Arizona actually  showed nearly half of coronavirus cases  there are between people are people  rather between 20 and 44 years old about  half